STAY UNTIL SOMEONE ELSE
TRANSITIONS INTO HIS POSITION.
>> Shannon: BUSY NEWS NIGHT AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
JOHN ROBERTS, THANK YOU.
WE’RE LEARNING MORE MORE ABOUT
JUST HOW INVOLVED THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA MAY HAVE BEEN IN
THE MONTHS LEADING UP TO THE
2016 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AS
THE RUSSIAN PROBE EXPANDED.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
>> THE TEXTS, CANDID,
UNVARNISHED, RAISING AN AWFUL
LOT OF QUESTIONS.
>> RON JOHNSON’S GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE RELEASED A
REPORT INCLUDING THE FBI TEXT
MESSAGES THAT DRAW NEW
CONNECTIONS TO PRESIDENT OBAMA.
SEPTEMBER 2016, 2 MONTHS AFTER
THE FBI CLOSED THE CLINTON
EMAILED CASE IN TWO MONTHS INTO
THE BUREAU’S RUSSIAN PROBE, THEN
FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK TEXTED
LISA PAGE USING BUREAU
SHORTHAND.
TALKING POINTS FOR DIRECTOR
COMEY?
PORTIS WANTS TO DO EVERYTHING WE
ARE DOING.
NOT CLEAR WHETHER STRZOK AND
PAGE ARE REFERRING TO EITHER
INVESTIGATION.
ON AN INTERVIEW, PRESIDENT OBAMA
INSISTED HE WAS NOT IN THE LOOP.
>> I DO NOT TALK TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS.
I DO NOT TALK TO FBI DIRECTORS
ABOUT PENDING INVESTIGATIONS.
WE HAVE A STRICT LINE AND ALWAYS
HAVE MAINTAINED IT.
>> IN THEN FBI DIRECTOR COMEY’S
JULY 2060 RECOMMENDATION AGAINST
TERMINAL CHARGES, THE EARLY
DRAFT SAID EMAILS BETWEEN
CLINTON AND PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD
PROBABLY BEEN COMPROMISED BY
HACKERS.
A WEEK BEFORE COMEY CLOSE THE
CASE, STRZOK AND OTHERS
INCLUDING HIS BOSS, HEAD OF FBI
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE, WATERED
DOWN THE LANGUAGE.
STRZOK WRITES "HOPE SO.
HE CHANGED PRESIDENT TO ANOTHER
SENIOR GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL."
THE REFERENCE WAS REMOVED
ALTOGETHER.
AFTER THE ELECTION, PAGE AND
STRZOK TEXTED ABOUT BEING
DEPRESSED.
IN NOVEMBER, PAGE WRITES I’VE
BOUGHT "ALL THE PRESIDENTS MEN."